could bachelor in paradise be over for  good after the hit ABC show halted  production on its fourth season of BI P  due to allegations of misconduct between  Demario Jackson and Corinne elympios a  source tells ET quote the show will  probably be done for good if a producer  witnesses that and it's on camera she or  he has to report it which is why this is  happening though there has been no  official word on the fate of the show  the cast of bachelor alums seemed to be  in good spirits following the filming  controversy in Mexico Jack stone posted  a few snaps drinking and hanging out  with fellow cast mates Astrid Locke and  Alexis waters while on their way home  Raven gates shared she was watching Game  six of the Stanley Cup Finals alongside  Vinnie van Tierra and Daniel mult B  writing go p-- reds the fourth season of  bachelor in paradise was set to air  August 8th  [Music]  you